Darcie my darling oh we are so blessed
to have you on our TVs again for the new
season of before the 90 days I got to
talk to you first of all about how
you're doing
during the corona stay-at-home times are
you with your daughters are you with
your sister
are you with Tom first of all thank you
for having me here today yes I'm in
Connecticut at home with the family my
daughter Stacy my father and yeah just
laying low right now but just you know
working on ourselves and just enjoying
only time and grace being you know the
moment is trying to be positive I would
almost a strong such a charge of you
what's going on in the world today and
we all gotta stick together and stay
strong so it doesn't spread so being at
home oh thanks great what's kind of I
don't know if funny is the right word
but for the 90 day people you guys are
used to communicating on skype and on
FaceTime with all that you're gonna what
tips would you have for people since
you've done this with money
long-distance relationships what are the
best ways to get close with someone
through a screen absolutely I mean it's
been down the block before you know
eight times all the time with
relationships overseas so how do you see
that the what I wanted through video and
I think you know we need to just embrace
that moment and just communicate
together as best as we can stay positive
give each other you know affirmations
hope and you know little reminders
little things you can do you know for
yourself and for others self-care tips
and just let everyone know that you know
you still love them and you're there I
gotta ask you I mean luckily we have the
season on our TVs right now and we are
all supposed to be staying at home as we
should but thank God for before the 90
days so what can we expect with this
next thing we're gonna see between you
and Tom which seems to be you may be
going to New York to see him first I
want to ask you you had seen the photos
of Tom with another woman so why not
just end it right then
well I think the episode might be coming
very soon Sunday nights are a very
exciting night to watch and yes by NATO
trip to New York you knew at the time
exactly how I felt there was a little
bit of a lack of communication during
the time I were sitting you know you
know just give things another go and I
just felt I deserve the respect of
communication and not be tangled I guess
you could say and in a sense and when I
saw the pictures you know I felt how I
felt about it but I think through
communication you can understand what
happened what was going on I don't like
to be left in the dust so we are in
relationship you just you want to know
exactly what's going on and I deserve
that respect though you did happen to
come to New York for business and
decided to meet and you guys can see the
outcome well we've heard your friends
people close to you saying they can't
seem to break apart from each other
Darcy and Tom just can't seem to break
apart why is that what is that hole that
you guys have you know Tom and I always
had a very close bond close relationship
over the years just Eve you know you
know hello every once in a while it was
really nice to hear how he was doing
obviously we were not gonna relationship
at that time that there was always a
connection a friendship first and
foremost my trust in him and then after
the break Jesse obviously movement
bonded and I got to experience beautiful
time I had you know overseas visiting
him for that time and also Stacey and
Florian got to meet him as well and
there's a lot of amazing times notes
ups and downs throughout it all but
better and what relationship but yeah I
just think that when I got back home you
know the communication kind of broke
down again I personally and used to
long-distance maybe he wasn't so we've
got a fear of that kind of you know made
him second-guess some things but I was
always there for him I was very open
about you know how I felt about him so
he knew exactly and I just wanted the
same respect in return
you mentioned Jesse I mean we've watched
you in Jesse's relationship now you and
Tom's which relationship would you say
you had like a stronger physical
chemistry
and which one is stronger emotional
chemistry in and and which one involved
more heartbreak well when I met Jessie
at design I was in the States we talked
for about four or five months prior to
going to Amsterdam and you know I heard
everything from him that I thought was
real and right and I just followed my
heart that was - your relationship was
toxic at times there was some beautiful
moments but there was a lot of you know
things that were kind of hard to work
through he was obviously much younger
than me and I have children he did talk
about a big future together
so what being started to break down it
was kind of like no I feel like I
deserved better than that as well I did
try to stand my ground and honor myself
and not let anyone take my power away
for myself my family and that was the
hard part because I don't know myself to
get hurt or anyone who might feel me to
get hurt which they did you know it was
very tough to go through those years in
that relationship
there was actually very strong physical
attractions I think you know when we
were together it was you know toxic and
then it was just fire you know very
passionate but I didn't want to continue
living my life that way because I felt
like I deserve better you know with Tom
it was something a little different
I felt obviously I had a stronger
connection and the sense of
communication in the beginning he had a
very strong friend on and you know in
the lip love start throwing deeper I
really I really trusted him and I
trusted his words and you know the
things that he wanted her life were very
similar to what I wanted and already had
him I seen a lot of commonality a lot of
similar things that he's gone through in
life so I related to him a lot more so
than Jesse so when I when there was an
issue or probably to talk about it we
didn't argue law just like that Jesse
was more true Moltres he could say you
know it was always something I was
offense but people change you know I
mean it's just you got to follow your
heart and your gut and something doesn't
feel right you got a picture of this do
you trust Tom now
um yeah I mean she's always you know
someone I'll always respect and you know
you guys just have to kind of continue
to have a lesson see oh Jessie and
Thomas become friends I keep hearing
this
hey yeah I've watched a little bit of
stuff on you know the media and heard
some of that you know exactly how I feel
about that as well but you can't really
just stop what other people choose to do
so for me to kind of fuel that fire and
my comments back on it like in the media
to them it's just it doesn't it doesn't
seat me that's not who I am as a person
if that's what they want then that's
what they want you know I just I'm
different and that's just their style
that's your that's Barry you're taking
the high road - thank you
so we're gonna see what happens with you
and Tom how would you tease that for the
fans will we see emotional breakdowns
will we see any you know breakups fights
between you guys what's to come
I think you guys will see I know you
guys saw some Cheers
last Sunday was bobbing with Stacie and
our different brain uh they know my
heart and they know that what I deserved
so for me to empower myself to feel
worthy of what Who I am as a person I
need to you know stand up for myself so
I don't think you guys will see many
more tears I think you guys will hear my
voice more and exactly what I deserve
and want in a relationship so I think
you guys will see a little bit of that
journey in the next episode or two and I
think people will understand that and
understand more Who I am a person is
this hard for you to watch back like I
can't imagine what it's like to watch
yourself crying and having like a really
deep moment like that um you know what I
never you know regret anything that I've
done in life and relationships it was a
risk I take and my heart will always be
open um I think it's very relatable I
don't mind showing my vulnerabilities my
tears my smiles my heart so I think it's
learning you know phase for myself as
well as long as I know who can
understand that journey because maybe
it's something that they can relate
you and help them through their journey
as well right
what I loved watching you and Stacy you
guys it's like you guys have your ups
and downs too but you see me just there
for each other no matter what what has
it been like for you two
twin sister relationship to get put
under a microscope how have you guys
learned or grown from it and what have
you learned about your relationship as
sisters yeah
Stacy and I have a very tight-knit we're
very much honoured as twin sisters me we
live together minute always live
together I think people will see a
little bit more of our story and how we
been in the past you know present in the
future we always have each other's back
in the end I know we have our moments
and our tit for tat at times with family
member dozen or twin but it's because we
love each other we want each other to
have the best so I just make me feel
about Tom is she like be done with mam
or what she will always have my back she
knows my concern and I think during that
time in the relationship it was really
tough because I was confused where I
stood in it but you guys will definitely
see coming up very soon some answers
anything you wish you'd done differently
looking back I know you learn from
everything but when you're watching back
like everything you've been through with
Tom really like okay I wish I'd done
this one moment or situation maybe when
I was in London I really really opened
my heart and I really was excited for
what the future holds and then we came
back you know he was busy I was busy I
was family and I was work as well I work
you know you know Los Angeles we have
hosted 11 he has his things going on so
I just think that I wish that I didn't
let myself feel a little chipped away at
or maybe just Eve because I was like
wait you just say you know you're you're
in love with me but like what's going on
I shouldn't you know shouldn't have to
wait or to understand us you're ready
for a relationship or not
just be honest let me know what's going
on so you know at least you
my time my people sir close and yes good
not ready just be honest and tell me so
it's it's a process and a a long process
but um right now sorry I love you you
know I'm watching it I'm thinking this
woman has done so much she's flown to
London she gave up her time she's put
her everything into it and so I know
plans want the best for you
thank you they do I get a lot of
messages every day like you know you're
such an inspiration by seeing you go
through your journey it's helped me
through mine and I just want you happy I
want to see you with the right person or
you know just kind of a you know
empowering yourself more I get a lot of
hit tons - I ignore that I just you know
want everyone to know to stay strong
stay in power and never let anyone take
your power away you deserve everything
beautiful in life and especially during
this time right now in this world it's
like nothing ever before everything's so
uncertain just kind of stay strong and
be there for the ones that you love the
most
so do you think tom was giving you what
you deserve at that kind no at that time
now I think maybe seeing each other in
person I really needed to kind of hone
in on that just really talked from our
heart at that point like when we see you
go to New York were you ready to fight
to forgive him and to move forward if he
didn't said the right things at that
point I was open to see what he had to
say you know I have a lot of love in my
heart like what would you have needed
for him to hear we're gonna watch it but
save it what would have what would did
you want to hear him say as you headed
to New York you know I just wanted I was
thinking a lot of things on my way there
actually and I just didn't want to feel
confused about where we were in our
relationship and that's what I felt the
time felt very confused where I stood
and what I meant to him so I really
wanted to hear do you love me are we
together like what is this what is going
on like be open be honest with me you
know how I feel I need to hear it from
you and I know there was pictures and
speculation and all that but regardless
all that I needed to hear it from him
and you know it was my best to do it in
person
over the phone at that time is having
flashbacks of the break would just be
like oh here I go again am I going to
New York for a break up happening is
this why he's - any person that's the
case don't want to come but I decided to
go in the end because I needed to feel
empowered for myself and stand strong
and not fear it
then what was he saying to get you to
come was he saying I still love you what
was what was coming from him after that
Skype call he didn't eat texted you know
just really want us to you know talk
talk this out and see where we stand I
think he really wanted to do it in
person and not so much with us on so it
was just so some few messages back and
forth were to me so we can kind of just
not really have any sort of
miscommunication you know through a
phone or so you wanted it in person so I
honored that and I went all right we
can't wait to watch Darcy being somebody
who's been in this franchise in two
relationships what he learns about love
and the way relationships work and how
have you evolved just being in this and
watching the shows back to right
watching the shows back and just going
through it personally I actually have
had a lot of time to just be more self
aware of you know who I am as a person
and heal from the past breaking some
past patterns that I've had in
relationships that did not work out I've
also been able to decide for myself what
what I want you know creating more of a
dream list and and knowing what I do
what I don't want their relationship and
instead of being always they give her
what I always felt like I was you know
the giver in the relationship or the one
that would never say say no you know is
very much of a yes person and now I feel
like I'm changing I'm evolving
I'm trance you know transforming into
someone more confident and more
self-assured and lens and I just want to
know that like so many people in this
world you know you can just release the
past when you're ready and maybe I
wasn't ready at the time but I'm ready
and I
yeah we'll just evening that's that
[ __ ] song you know if you could just
last question give me a couple of
adjectives a sentence or two about what
we can expect tease the rest of the
journey we will see between you and
Thomas season okay I would say to choose
anything Darcy is empowered loving
herself inside and out embracing her
loved ones and keeping her eye on the
prize how are you now are you happy now
very happy very happy all right family
first you know and as long as I'm with
family that's all that matters
[Music]